thanks for joining us
well MSN reporting Americans now owe
over one trillion dollars on our cars
Americans in the u.s. Oh a collective
1.07 trillion dollars in debt on their
vehicles according to Experian the
amount is a record high and as interest
rates increase and monthly payments
become less affordable it could create
headwinds for lenders auto loan demand
has been an important source of revenue
for the lenders and automakers however
rates are increasing now that the
Federal Reserve is tightening rates and
that could pose a problem for
cash-strapped consumers
despite stretching the payments out
Experian reports that the average new
car loan in the fourth quarter increased
to thirty thousand six hundred and
twenty one dollars a record and that the
average monthly car loan is now 506
dollars a month in America and the
typical borrower about 32% of the
borrower's one out of three chose a 73
to 84 month loan last quarter and
despite stretching the payments out to
lower the monthly bill the percentage of
delinquent auto loans is on the upswing
well no kidding our up
with cars in this culture is over the
top now I'm a boy I like cars I've got
some nice cars I'm not against you
having a nice car a $30,000 car loan
with a $500 a month payment is what's
called stupid financially mathematically
moronic because let me tell you what a
$30,000 car is worth four years after
you buy it
11,000 now if you want to take a $30,000
car and turn it into $11,000 car that's
fine you need to be able to afford to do
that I've certainly lost more than that
on the vehicles that I owned in the last
48 months I however can afford it and
the reason I can afford it is I haven't
had car notes because car notes will
keep you from becoming wealthy car
payment is the mantra of the
middle-class if you want to be sure you
stay stuck financially in the middle
class or lower middle class keep a
stupid car payment that will pretty much
guarantee it because $500 a month
invested from age 30 to age 70
and a decent growth stock mutual fund in
your Roth IRA is over five million
dollars on average that's what that car
payment is costing you and then we get
to retirement we say I sure hope the
government which is well known for its
ability to handle money will take care
of me this is straight-up stupid people
and it's getting nowhere but worse Ford
and General Motors have bounced back on
your back they went down down down down
down during the Great Recession and
their sales are up up up up up on your
back and they make more money lending
you money than they do selling cars when
are you going to realize this and until
you do realize this and stop it well
you're always going to have a car
payment says the loser you hang out with
losers that you're going to be one be
careful who you run around with always
going to the core payment thirty
thousand six hundred twenty one dollars
and five hundred six dollar car payment
over seventy three to eighty four months
is the average now if this doesn't sound
like stupid on steroids I don't know
what does this is unbelievable
a trillion dollars in student loan debt
a trillion dollars in car debt and you
scratch your head and wonder why in the
richest country the world has ever known
most industrious inventive group of
people on the freakin planet and we sit
here a bunch of us broke it's ridiculous
you make so much money in your working
lifetime but a trillion dollars in
student loan debt and a trillion dollars
in car debt you don't think that puts a
drain on the economy you don't make that
puts a drain on the average household
well it keeps you from being worth five
million dollars more than you would have
been worth when you retire the average
which means that half the people are
above that it's Apple people are worse
than that which means that some of you
are listening to me right now seven
hundred dollar car payments some of you
have two five hundred dollar car
payments okay get a mirror and look at
what stupid looks like that's
straight-up stupid there is no possible
way you can build wealth doing that you
can't earn enough money to outrun stupid
at that pace it will tackle you from
behind you have got to stop and look at
those mathematics on this it is crazy
crazy guys
you can live your dreams in this you can
live your dreams in America today you
can do anything you want to be anything
you want to be you you can build wealth
every one of you just about every one of
you listening to me could be
millionaires every single one of you
listening to me could be a millionaire
but not with 500 car payments you won't
be not with car payments at all and so
this whole idea of the largest thing you
buy as consumers that goes down in value
a car now again if you'll just drive
like no one else
you know just drive you get you a hoopty
drive like no one else later you can
drive like no one else when you're a
millionaire you can go buy a car and
write a cheque for it and it can go down
in value and you won't notice it but
it's not that big a percentage of your
world but some of you your entire
freakin net worth you're riding in it
right now
and it's going backwards in value while
you're sitting at the stoplight trying
to impress that person you will never
meet you just lost a thousand bucks it's
crazy
you cannot get ahead like that you've
got to stop it trillion dollars in car
death America now ah I will always have
a job this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]